Fry. Do you have to make such a racket? What
is that contraption?
It's a broom bender. Today's a big day, and I
want the place to look nice for Leela.
Oh, just like the lovely black snow of Old
London.
Hey, before Leila shows up and judges our
swinging bachelor lifestyle, we should have
one last cabbage fight. I got a crate of
really rotten ones.
I don't know. Now that Leela's moving in, I kind
of want to show her-
Let me finish.
I want to
show her. Show her show.
I want to.
All right.
That's it.
Oh!
Whoa, oh, oh.
Hey, that's the vase I keep my cabbages in.
Wow. It's so much cleaner than the last time
I was here.
Leela, come in.
Welcome to your new home.
Our new home.
Where should I put my things? I don't see a
dresser.
Oh, let the judgment thing begin.
Do you have any hangers? I can put my things
in this tiny closet.
That tiny closet is my room.
Also, we don't have any hangers, but we can
order some from Momazon.
Oh, yeah. They have all the top, slightly
misspelled brands.
Ha! Hangers.
I'll get five. No, wait. There's free
shipping on 1000.
Wow. Fast delivery.
Let's also get a shoe caddy so we don't track
mud into the room.
Right. Don't want to get mud on the cabbages.
Hey, you aren't the only ones who live here.